Stacks can be really useful when you
only care about the most recent elements
or the order in which you see and
save elements actually matters.
Maybe you have a page like a news feed.
You'll need to access the more
recent elements more quickly and
more frequently, but
you may need to show all of the elements
when the user scrolls down.
There is some specific terminology
associated with stacks.
When you add an element to a stack,
the operation is called
push instead of insert.
When you take an element
off of the stack,
the operation is called
a pop instead of remove.
Remember all you need here is to look
at the top element of the stack.
So the operation should be
constant time for both operations.
Now here's a possibly confusing point
because a stack is pretty abstract,
it could actually be implemented
with another data type.
What each element looks like and
how there’s connected aren't
actually specified, just the methods for
adding and removing elements.
For example you could use a link
list to implement a stack.
You would keep track of the front
of a single link list and
just keep adding elements
on top as you went.
I also want to note that you
might see the notation L.I.F.O.
associated with stacks.
This acronym means Last In, First Out.
All it's saying is the last element you
put on the stack when you use push,
is always the first one you
get out when you use pop.
It's just a fancy way of saying
something you hopefully already know
about Stacks.